author Ronald Kessler how much damage
was done to American security by Russian
attempts to penetrate the US Embassy in
Moscow when we last tuned into this we
were told that first the KGB had been
allowed to run around wild in the
embassy then we were told nothing ever
happened was it turned out it was much
worse than what we heard originally the
CIA and NSA actually found bugging
devices on the CIA cipher machines and
as a result of that some 25 Soviets were
executed is either real or suspected CIA
agents basically the whole CIA station
in Moscow was closed down because of
this penetration how much lasting damage
well it's going to take many years for
for any Soviets to want to cooperate
with the CIA in Moscow in addition the
KGB was able to read communications of
the State Department on on arms
negotiations it's hard to reconstruct
just just what kind of damage that did
but basically we have a situation where
the KGB is still effectively spies in
the United States but in the Soviet
Union as far as human intelligence is
concerned we there's a tremendous
imbalance the book is Moscow station how
the KGB penetrated the American Embassy
the author is Ronald Kessler who joins
us today is previously written the life
insurance game the richest man in the
world and spy versus spy with an
investigative reporter for The
Washington Post from 1970 to 1987 worked
for The Wall Street Journal from 68 to
70 and before that worked for the
Worcester Telegram and the Boston Herald
originally from Belmont Massachusetts
and I guess since we're both in the same
area I could say the Worcester Telegram
exactly we'll be taking your calls in
just a few moments the numbers we listed
throughout the show at the bottom of the
screen and remember the 30-day policy if
you've called in within the last month
wait let's give someone else a chance to
get through ok how could this have
happened you would think that in this
most sensitive post in the world that
the security would be one
would be fantastic but it was just the
opposite the security was not as good as
your local grocery store first of all I
sent these inexperienced 21 year old
Marines in there without wives not
allowing them to have girls in their
rooms they were sitting ducks for the
KGB's entrapment efforts the KGB would
send in these very attractive swallows
as they call them seductive young women
to to entice the Marines and and it was
just no match and that's exactly how
lone tree began his violence exactly how
brace he began his pie in addition you
had the State Department not really
caring very much about security the
diplomats have this ingrained attitude
that somehow security impairs their
their their efforts to improve relations
with the Soviets which which simply is
is someone has no connection whatsoever
you can you can have security and you're
in your house for example and and be
friendly with your neighbors but that
doesn't mean you have to let them in or
leave your leave your door unlocked all
night and that's basically what happened
after midnight there was one marine who
guarded the whole embassy he was he had
access he gave access to people in the
front entrance he also guarded the ninth
floor where the communications room was
the alarms were such that they could be
turned off by the marine without any
record being kept of when they were
turned off he also had the codes to
enter the CPU or the communications room
so really it was it was not very
difficult to to let the KGB into the
communications area and that's just what
happened in addition on top of all this
you had the naval Investigative Service
which later tried to find out what
happened tried to bring the perpetrators
to justice and they simply were not
equipped to conduct an espionage
investigation normally the FBI does that
they're very experienced and they're
very good at it and the N is really
totally botched this investigation you
mentioned earlier that the first reports
came out said one thing that other
reports came out gave a differing
picture why did that happen
it began when lonetree confessed and he
didn't confess to letting people into
the embassy just to give him
information to the KGB which in fact he
did to much greater extent them came out
at the time he actually gave him floor
plans details of how alarms work names
of CIA officers but then Arnold Bracy
the second marine involved confessed to
actually letting the KGB into the
embassy and it was very detailed
confession a very credible confession
but he recanted and as soon as he
recanted the whole scandal went away
because the NIS had not done their basic
homework before they confronted Bracy
they didn't develop any background
information on him
and so after he confessed it was very
difficult to corroborate his confession
because they had mass direct questions
and so that was it and then as it turned
out about six months later the NSA and
primarily the NSA began examining the
communications equipment here in
Washington with x-rays and spectroscopic
analysis and that's when they found that
in fact microchips in the printers had
been replaced that the power line to the
CPU had been replaced and that in fact
they're still studying how these bugs
work which is exactly the same situation
that happened with the new embassy
around the corner from the old embassy
in Moscow and the same pattern existed
there that is the same pattern of
concealing what the findings were the
new embassy bugs were first found in
1982 the CI sort of began whispering
this to the Senate Intelligence
Committee but first they would refer to
them as anomalies and it wasn't until
about last year that we were finally
told yet told that yes there were bugs
in the new embassy in fact that the
whole embassy was was one big bugging
device and that it was so bad that there
was no way that this building could be
used and the only solution was to tear
it down that's what's happened in this
case the CIA has issued what appeared to
be a denial that there were bugs but
actually there are quite a few loopholes
in that in that statement and they're
doing the same thing with this they're
avoiding confronting the issue they're
avoiding saying publicly that in fact
bugs were found they're taking a
position that they're still studying it
they're still trying to figure out how
they
work we don't know fully what the KGB
get out of this and it's it's a pattern
that doesn't lend itself to to to reform
in the situation let's go to the phones
Lincoln Nebraska you're on the air I
have a question for the off I'm nineteen
year old and I know if you how you feel
about the fact that we entrust this kind
of information this kind of secrecy to
these young young American overseas and
abroad and and if you could expand on
that because I know that I have strong
feelings against the fact that such
secrecy is entrusted to these young
gentlemen and expect these gentlemen are
expect and to uphold the the you know
the bond that we have the secrecy and I
I need to know what you feel how you
feel about that well I agree with you
the logical solution would be to send in
mature married experienced professional
guards such as the Executive Protective
Service officers who protect embassies
in Washington people who are well-paid
who choose that as a profession rather
than Marines who don't necessarily want
to be guards they join the Marines to
fight and they may do a wonderful job of
that and we may be very proud of them in
that in that regard but but when it
comes to to matching wits with the KGB
it's just a joke there's no way that
they can do that
they're very naive and a lot of them are
involved in various problems there have
been a lot of drug problems a lot of
other criminal activities by a large
percentage 10% we exact of the marine
security guards in our embassies
overseas let's go right here at home to
Washington DC yes I didn't hear that
last question I hope this isn't a
duplicate of it but when I was in the
Marine Corps embassy Duty was considered
an excellent job and only the elite had
it according to what I heard I never had
it but what has happened that was the
tradition but but somehow as the Marine
Corps felt that that they weren't
getting enough
recruits and they weren't allowed to
have enough positions they began sending
the best Marines to fighting units and
just to some extent the the the less
qualified Marines were being sent to
guard duty let's go out to the west
coast - Komal Washington you're on air
yes this is called the letterhead not
one word not one word of this do I
believe is true about those Marines in
Moscow I don't know why this came about
they have no idea why it came about but
there's a whole lot that could snow that
this is not true I can't understand any
marine soul or anybody doing anything
like this that's all laughter well it's
very hard to understand criminal
activity period you know why would
anybody take a chance at robbing a bank
and end up in prison for the rest of his
life it is inconceivable to a law about
in person but yet it happens people do
commit espionage Walker committed
espionage Pelton and and we have the
same situation here alone he was
convicted he admitted that he did this
and to say no I can't believe it and
these are patriotic people and I don't
want to hear about it is to simply
perpetuate the situation that created
this it's a naive attitude that we
Americans tend to have about espionage
and if we don't realize that it's
happening obviously it's going to happen
even more it's go up to Boston
Massachusetts you're on the air
good morning join I am with friends of
the Wampanoags here in New England and
particularly interest in Native American
justice it seems to me the lone tree was
sort of set up and I'm wondering what
you think about his having us another
trial or whatever it takes to get him
out of Leavenworth
well just because laundry happens to be
from a man
does not mean that he was set up is that
what you feel she's gone as I said he
confessed he his confession was
corroborated he said he was about to
meet with certain KGB officers and sure
enough he these KGB officers did show up
at the very same place where he said
they were going to show up and he's
since given much more information about
what he did there and it's really
unfortunate that people would would say
well because this person is black or
Jewish or [ __ ] or or Indian that
therefore he's innocent
that's just foolishness nice calls from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania go right ahead
yes thank you I am so intrigued by your
methods used in investigative reporting
particularly of this nature where
everything is so secretive that's one
comment I wish to make and then I'm
going to tell you about something that I
think also needs investigation and how
you would be able to go about it whether
or not you could in other words the
number of missiles at this country
purposed in the last eight or nine years
stored sold and complete inventory on my
have a reason for that
I knew a controller who works in a
high-tech corporation he's worked there
for 12 years
at one point well into the Reagan
administration he made one comment he
said my god we're making so many
missiles I don't know what the hell
they're doing with them I'm concerned
about the ones being sold to Iraq and
Iran to continue the war for them to
knock each other off well as well beyond
the scope of my book as for my methods
in this investigation I had previously
done a book called spy versus spy which
is on how the FBI tracked spies and so I
got some familiarity with how this whole
world works what the real world of spine
is all about as opposed to the fictional
world and in the course of that I
developed some sources and I heard that
there was more there that happened in
Moscow than we've heard about but beyond
that it was simply a straight JA
investigative job of interviewing almost
everybody there
and trying to piece together what
happened and really there was no magical
method it was it was just a lot of hard
work frankly it's slaughter New Mexico
you're on c-span
yes sir Ron yes did you cover the trial
that lone tree under whit no I had not
become interested in about time did are
you aware that the commander had picks a
jury yes in other words the jury wasn't
selected at random uh yes yes
is that a fair jury well the fact is
that the military juries do acquit
people and in fact in the case of Bracy
the charges were dismissed by the
military on his case and in some ways
the the military can actually be more
fair than the than the civilian justice
system a lot of people in the military
don't necessarily want to go along with
with what what they think the commander
wants and they want to give the person a
fair trial and I think that that the
record of the military justice system
indicates that that justice does prevail
there Bennington Vermont is our next
call
yes mr. kressler yes uh I've followed
the story for a little time and produced
digest from the first came up I'm
wondering have we forbidden the Soviets
from taking back a piece of their
embassy in Washington DC yes as far as
the office space is concerned they're
not allowed in there although some
suspicions that they might go in there
at night and and do bugging there but
and likewise in Moscow we have not
occupied our office space in both cities
the residential areas are occupied
you talk a lot in the book or it's
mentioned often about the ninth floor
room could you expand on a little bit
for us now 9th floor is is where the
ambassador's office is and it's also
where the CPU is the CPU is a enclosed
room the size of several living rooms in
an average home which is supposed to
prevent radio waves from entering the
room or leaving the room it's simply a
metal sheath enclosure and the idea is
that we don't want to have any bugging
devices or signals going out of there on
the other hand the power line is very
vulnerable to attack because you still
have to get power into that room and
it's possible to introduce signals on
the power line especially if you replace
the para line which is what happened in
this case go to Peekskill New York
you're next mr. Kessler yes first I
comment and I don't have a question it
appears to me that in general the
American community is either lulled or
is becoming complacent by the changes
that are occurring in the Soviet Union
and I suspected by and large we mistake
these changes as something that is
affecting us and that is we should not
worry about the threat of communism that
has I guess been around for about 70
years and initially the Soviets told us
outright that their ultimate goal was to
conquer the world I believe within this
past year they have officially stated
that this is not their goal however um
Americans by and large feel that all you
have to do is talk to the Soviets that
the people basically are all the same we
in this country they in the Soviet Union
and so consequently it's the
government's that may be so to an extent
but young Marines in Soviet embassy or
anywhere else in the world or young
Americans who are
how possibly are going over to the
Soviet Union are not aware of the
continuing espionage and the
intelligence of the KGB and the effort
that the KGB is still continuing and
undermining our policies and our
government most Americans today are
still not aware that half of the Soviet
Union for example is non Russian
ethnically that the Ukrainians or
Armenians or Latvians still do not wish
to be part of that Empire so my question
to you sir is do you feel that if an
educational program a national
educational program could be promoted to
somehow tell Americans that the threat
is still continuing and if so do you
have any idea how that could be done sir
well you know I certainly agree with you
that the threat continues we have to
remain strong not only as far as Soviets
are concerned but but in relation to
other countries including countries that
pursue terrorist policies and I think
the president has certainly indicated
that that we still you know have to be
on our guard on the other hand we don't
want to close our eyes the fact that the
changes have been made that that by both
actions and words the Soviets have
showed that they are not pursuing
expansionist policies now that could
change Gorbachev can be killed whatever
but and so we do have to remain strong
so it's it's you know it's somewhat it's
a changing situation and and I think
just who our media through through what
what Bush has said and what other
political leaders have said the American
people probably do get the message that
that there have been changes and we
don't want to you know be belligerent
with them at the same time we still have
to remain
strong and on our guard
technically Moscow station was due out
in March but is it in the bookstores now
did you get it in most bookstores it is
there the official publication date is
enlarged them let's go down to Austin
Texas
you're on c-span have a question about
CIA in the question FBI about Edward Lee
Howard in the book the spot who got away
by David wise I talked to the author of
this book about eight months ago on
c-span and he couldn't answer either one
of these questions on hoping maybe you
can't but Edward Lee Howard was
discovered to have alcohol and drug
problems by the CIA
they basically disbarred him and cut him
loose and then he did all sorts of
damage to our country in the CIA why
didn't the CIA reassign him put him in
some lesser job in this country and keep
an eye on him instead of just cutting
him loose to where he could just go off
like a loose cannon that's question
number one in the second question when
the FBI realized what he was doing
why did they put such a jr. in rookie
FBI agent to watch him in under
surveillance and he eventually got away
and escaped out of the country well
those are extremely tough questions I
kind of stand why David wise had trouble
answering them there there is no answer
it's simply unthinkable lack of judgment
and it's simply basic that if somebody
is has an alcohol problem and also has
all these secrets about what happened
how the CIA operates in Moscow that you
don't just fire them without letting
them find another job and but the more
important question to me is why are
those people who made those judgments
still at the CIA why is it that in this
government in general we don't have a
tradition of at least firing people who
make mistakes especially egregious
mistakes that cause serious damage
to our security that's I think the more
important question because you're always
going to have mistakes to one degree or
another but to to leave these people to
create a situation where people are
unaccountable
and and don't suffer any reprisals for
their actions just encourages more of
these mistakes let's go to Rialto
California you're next good morning good
morning I like to ask that as far as the
CIA and the embassy in all of this is
concerned I think that basically we
should get back to basics I think things
have just really blown out of proportion
and things have been made bigger than
what it really is and I think that if we
could get up some kind of resources or
plans so that of the CIA or the military
that's involved should have some kind of
training of from the beginning because
like other revolution things people have
heard from the wars and what things have
happened over the years they really
don't know all we know is what we read
and are told about there are certain
things that people should know about
that US is specifically secret but if we
keep on letting so many different people
that has a lot of
I can't think of the word but but to get
to the point is that I think that we
should of have some kind of training
that when these young kids come out of
high school and go off into the service
and everything they should have a
program where they are trying to to
respect and protect their home all right
thank you very much I think we have the
points respond well we basically just
have to do our jobs better and not
simply defend past mistakes which is
what these agencies have been doing the
Marine Corps still sends in these young
and experienced Marines they've
increased training by you know one or
two hours in counterintelligence which
is which is nothing the basic problem
remains that that the Marines shouldn't
be sent there in the first place the
state environment still doesn't care
very much about security Naval
Investigative Service still investigate
investigates espionage when they totally
screwed up all these espionage
investigations and you know it's we
don't want to just throw up our hands
and say well we don't understand what's
going on here and let's just sort of
educate the whole American public there
are very specific things that need to be
done and and they're not being done and
I think that that's the problem and and
and beyond that that that there's no
accountability in the government there's
no mechanism for dealing with mistakes
like this let's go up to New York City
for our next call you're on c-span
good morning our two comments I'd like
you to comment on one it would appear
throughout history that is any system
whether it's US Steel or US Marines get
bureaucratized the skills needed to
reach decision-making positions are not
the ones that are necessary to make the
decisions good ones our military history
of the past listen to the second world
war has not been indicator of great
competence
it seems to me that some analysis should
be made of the people who chose and put
those young Marines in the embassies
rather than simply trying to blame the
poor young Marines I agree in Tallinn
okay one other other thing I'd like you
to comment on and now disconnect
I was reading at John McCrae the other
day and had a tentative thought
considering that the sort of manic
paranoid Psychopaths that have been
running the Soviet Union until perhaps
lately it's perhaps been a very good
thing that they thought at least they
knew what's going on through various
modes which they had rather high
certainty in the British secret service
and we perhaps been safer since the
second world war because of that it's a
perhaps irrational to think that their
confidence in spying has helped us but
I'd like to comment on that too
I think that's true I think that
ultimately intelligence that's balanced
that that's pretty much equal actually
as a stabilizing influence because both
sides know what the other side is doing
and that helps prevent misapprehensions
paranoia etc and that's fine the problem
is when there's a big imbalance between
one side on the other side and all of a
sudden the side that's getting much more
intelligence and knows much more starts
thinking that they are superior and they
can they can circumvent our defenses and
then you have a situation where where we
are in a very disadvantageous position
so that's why you have to have
intelligence on both sides and and
neither side should should be winning
because because that that can lead to a
dangerous situation as for your first
point that's exactly what happened in
this case that is the the lower level
well not only Gracie and lonetree who
certainly you know did did confess to
espionage but other Marines who engaged
in very small infractions going to a bar
with Soviet woman or having even sex
with with a Soviet woman who and it may
or may not have known that there were
Soviets suffered tremendous setbacks to
their careers whereas the people who
really made the decisions that led to
this have suffered no reprisals
whatsoever for example one of the the
detachment commander in Moscow who
recommended that lonetree be removed
from Moscow because he had a drinking
problem
he was basically just a flake he
couldn't do his job right he was simply
a menace that the other Marines there
recommended that he be removed and yet
the person over that accompany who was
based in West Germany overruled that
recommendation and would not remove
longtree and a few months later loan
tree began spying
the person who overruled the detachment
commander is still a Marine nothing's
happened to him nothing's happened to
his career and yet these these these
young men who never should have been
sent there in the first place have
suffered severe setbacks to their
careers and their lives let's go down to
Houston Texas you're on c-span go right
ahead oh yes sir thank you I'm very
happy to have this forum with your
author this morning to express an awful
lot of concern that I have had since
this whole thing came up but the Embassy
in Moscow that's my personal opinion an
intelligent woman that this whole thing
is a Marx Brothers comedy perpetrator
minds of the American people who think
it is a joke there is no way in this
world people should take this seriously
now there might be something behind it
very serious but I think you like at the
Roman table because the American people
are not stupid now you know yourself
that IRS when they get somebody who's
lagging behind in their pack a little
bit you know and rinky-dink tax deal
those IRS agents will come to your house
put a lien on your house none of these
little guys get away they are brought
just now here we have the highest levels
of government can be right who we know a
spy for the KGB sophisticated than all
that sort of thing and you cannot tell
me that good conscience this government
should allow an embassy like that to be
exposed even in the smallest way to the
KGB infiltration thank let me just jump
in here because we have a lot of calls
and not only a few minutes left could
you respond well I certainly agree with
you the and one one particular problem
is that that the Congress at this point
has not stepped in and tried to find out
really what happened here they pretty
much taken the word of the CIA that may
be nothing but nothing happened or the
things are still being studied or it
still being an or maybe they're
anomalies and the intelligence
committees have not really probed into
this and they've largely taken the word
of the CIA and until you know Congress
gets involved nothing's going to happen
go long-distance Honolulu Hawaii go
right ahead
yes good morning or evening just depend
on where you are about these specific
questions for mr. Kessler and the first
one is where the commanding officers are
these men disciplined also in how birds
do what happened absolutely not no
officer was this one it was it was
basically a cover-up within the Marine
Corps they were very happy to let these
young men take the hits and as for
themselves they exonerated exonerated
themselves you know follow-up yeah I've
got two more two more questions
okay I'll have to move along here
because you all
not urban KGB how many KGB agents
business or operating in Janette the
United States now what are they doing
who's tracking them and the last
question is how many are there KGB and
upper levels of our government specially
policymaking agencies there first of all
as far as overt agents are concerned
there are 6,000 officials from Soviet
bloc countries here about a third of
them are believed to be either KGB or
GRU intelligence officers in addition
there are many so-called illegals who
are not attached to any embassies and we
don't know how many there are those as
for other so-called illegals let's say
who are spies have infiltrated
government agencies just like bank fraud
we we find a certain amount of it but we
know that there's much more out there
and I think that's true in this case
there was one Czech intelligence service
officer called kosher who became a mole
in the CIA for 12 years and we can be
sure that there are many more out there
who have not been caught go down to
Spartanburg South Carolina go right
ahead thank you good morning mr. Khosla
hi as a former Marine I have to be
somewhat defense of what appears to be
and I'm sorry if I say this with any
degradation what appears to be a blanket
condemnation I don't disagree with the
fact that yes it needs to be a looking
at the system but the Marine Corps is
this time is the technical operating
strength of 190 ninety seven thousand of
those one hundred ninety seven thousand
the quote elite hesitate to use that
term but it's still the most difficult
duty to get into recruitment the drill
instructor field and embassy duty when
you take in consideration you made a
comment earlier there's a 10% problem
that appears awfully high and there's
also you pointed out that war who was
found guilty was fine but that's kind of
an inference that Walker was also a
Marine and he was out he was in the Navy
and it just it appears and again it the
inference is that the Marine Corps
overall has a problem
Benedict Arnold which is one person
certainly he was not inflective of the
entire country turn
Marine Corps is very patriotic and
well-trained and and and we can be proud
of the Marine Corps and yes there are
always will be a few spies out there and
to some extent we can't do anything
about it but the problem is that there's
a systemic situation here that these
Marines who are sent for guard duty
particularly in Moscow are not the best
qualified lonetree was sent out there
and he could barely fire a gun I mean he
was it was so slow mentally and had such
poor judgment and and then nothing was
done about it and no action has been
taken against the people who made these
decisions and in fact they're still
sending the same kind of people out
there so that's a situation where we're
really there is a basic problem and
until that is rooted out we have to we
have to continue to criticize the Marine
Corps one more call let's go down to
Tampa Florida you're on the air
hello yes you're on the air go right
ahead this is Brooks Dixon go right
ahead
I'm interested in discussing a point the
young lady made a while ago about the
small fry being put in the skillet and
while the big fish jump out of pan and I
didn't with this author he possibly has
an opinion that I could share or
disagree with ollie north is a small fry
the special prosecutor and Jim Wright
are two chefs that are putting the burn
on every human being in this nation who
gives a hoot inhale your Kentucky about
the small fry of us who have to fight
these wars what does he suggest can be
done to keep ollie north and his type
still willing to defend this country by
whatever means possible and he didn't
lie to Congress Congress is a liar I
disagree I think first of all that Ollie
north is not a small fry at all he was
on the National Security Council he had
one of the most important positions in
the security of our nation and
and he blew it he not only lied to
Congress but he also violated our laws
and what is it that we're trying to
defend what is the whole purpose of our
security system and our defenses is to
preserve our system of government which
is a system of laws and if we say we can
just do whatever we want all the North
didn't agree with Congress so therefore
he's going to go deal with the Contras
then we're doing exactly what the
Soviets do and that's what we're trying
to protect we're trying to protect our
system Moscow station how the KGB
penetrated the American Embassy is now
in bookstores Ronald Kessler thank you
very much for joining us
I enjoyed it thank you and thanks for
your calls and have a good day